foreign
it was the wildest moment in live
television history we are still
processing what just went down with Will
Smith and Chris Rock at the 94th annual
Academy Award so the moment arrived
after the comedian made a joke about
Jada Pinkett Smith's hair prompting will
to storm on stage and slap Chris before
returning to his seat and yelling from
the crowd now the whole moment was muted
on the broadcast but the uncensored
exchange was captured via Japanese
television take a look at this I
[Applause]
wow wow
[Applause]
Will Smith just smacked out of me
wow dude yeah it was a GI Jane joke
I'm going to okay
oh okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
Television clearly the joke didn't go
over well Chris mentioned that Jada
looks like she could star in GI Jane
mocking her bald head Jada has been very
open about her hair loss battle as she
suffers from alopecia now as captured by
The Hollywood Reporter columnist Scott
Feinberg during commercial break will
his scene pulled aside and comforted by
Denzel Washington and Tyler Perry as he
appears to wipe tears from his eyes and
with the internet debating whether this
was real or a scripted bid an executive
editor at variety added on Twitter as
someone who works for the Oscars told me
that Chris Rock was not interrupted by
Will Smith at rehearsals yesterday it
was not supposed to happen it was real
in another Will Smith news he just took
home the top actor prize for his role as
Venus and Serena Williams father in King
Richard his cops Will's numerous
accolades for this role including best
actor at the bafta and Critics Choice
Awards